بالنسبة لي للخروج ، فإن حبال الأمان
هي نوع من التعليق في هاتشواي
روجر والطقس رائع ،
هذا المنظر لمايك هوبكنز يخرج من
غرفة معادلة الضغط
القادمة من داخل
جزء قفل المعدات والكاميرا التي رأيناها
soichinoguchi تم إعدادها مسبقًا
بالفعل  خارج الفتحة ، ينضم إلى
قفاز ناسا المنتصر ،
وستكون قادرًا على التمييز بينهما اليوم من
خلال الخطوط على بدلات الفضاء الخاصة بهم ،
يرتدي هوبكنز بدلة غير مميزة في
حين أن قفاز المنتصر سيكون له
حلقات حمراء حول أرجل بدلة الفضاء الخاصة به
أه مع الضوء الأخضر المصباح  لأعلى ، دعنا نرى
أن علامة تبويب مفتاح الواقع الافتراضي الخاصة بك تبدو
مختلفة قليلاً عن الاثنين الآخرين القادمين بهذه
الطريقة ،
حسنًا ،
حسنًا ، هذا قليل من اللعب ولكن
الأمر متروك لديك ثلاث علامات تبويب لأعلى
أه أعطني الانحراف في كل اتجاه وسأقوم
بالتحقق منه  مقابضك الأكثر أمانًا ،
حسنًا ، أنت على حق ، مقابض الورق
لأسفل ، أغلق باب وحدة التحكم اليدوي
المحطة الفضائية التي تسافر حول
الأرض بسرعة
17500 ميل في الساعة أسفل
يسارك أكثر أمانًا  المقبض هو المقبض الصحيح الأكثر أمانًا
لأسفل
والباب مغلق
ومن نقطة غطاء الأمان ،
انظر اثنين على حلقة D اليمنى ، تم
قفلهما بدون قفل ولدي خطاف التثبيت الخاص بك
، وهو فقط لتأكيد القادوس الذي
قلته
الشريط الأبيض الأمامي مرئي على m3 ،
هذا صحيح ،
حسنًا ، هذا تكوين جيد ، يتم إغلاق qd
كما هو متوقع